[Music]
baker mayfield made good on his wager
with saquon barkley barkley won the
offensive rookie of the year awards so
baker mayfield had a chain commissioned
and made and uh sent to saquon barkley
quads is what baker mayfield chose to
put on the chain so what we chose to do
inspired by that friendly wager between
baker mayfield and saquon barkley two of
the great rookies from last year but
there were plenty of great rookies who
will make the biggest jump in year two
of his nfl career when we take into
account the 2018 rookies moving forward
into 2019. that's today's draft chris
you're on the clock heads or tails go
ahead rig coin toss you're going to get
the first pick although this is one of
those days where there isn't a clear and
obvious number one so i'll probably win
the question how many times a week does
do we think mike says that every time
every time because it's chills
started off on a monday the right way
kristen tails yeah
whoo
okay all right what do you got all right
biggest jump gosh this is it's a tough
one here
um
i'm gonna go with the quarterback for
the new york jets and sam darnold though
that's where i'm going to start it off
and you know sam darnold not that it was
like bad last year it was very good i
mean what we saw at the end of the year
was really promising but i don't think
we saw last year what you know what he
can beat in in totality and of course he
was injured you know he had some early
season struggles then he got injured
then he came back and showed us like wow
some big time talent towards the end of
the year but i'm expecting a big jump
from sam darnold this year one why
because i think the player is talented i
mean you know good arm i'm not gonna sit
here and go oh it's a great arm but it's
unbelievably quick release it's
unbelievably accurate and the ball is on
the screws in the short to intermediate
pass game he's great at playing backyard
football we saw that and man the support
cast around him is what really drives me
here you know jamison crowder at slot
receiver they got good tight end play
they improved the offensive line le'veon
bell adam gase i just look at all those
things and think this is a sophomore
that if there was a sophomore of the
year award in the nfl he will be in the
running for it this year
oh blasphemy from you now you've spent
the last 18 months relentlessly hyping
another quarterback in the afc east and
you pull the okie doke now when the
chips are gonna do this and you don't go
josh allen did you think i was not gonna
take josh i did a round two i didn't i
thought you might not i thought i was
gonna be able to steal both of them
that's where i was saying it was tough i
didn't know if i wanted to go allen or
darnold first
yeah but whichever one you were taking i
was taking the other one and i think
they're interchangeable when you
actually may have taken the wrong one
because i think josh allen has superstar
potential you know that yeah you've been
all over josh allen as a potentially
star quarterback and you know we here's
the here's the thing
and and here's where i'll concede that
you may have picked the right guy
allen did more last year than darnold so
it's going to be harder for him to have
a bigger jump this year because he's
starting from a higher platform than
darnold he showed because he had a
better rookie year yeah he showed more
big time plays and potential to where
you know again i know we have both said
this but
we buffalo was not in the playoff hunt
on sundays last year but i know you and
i were always like hitting each other on
the shoulder like look at number 17 here
he goes again with some crazy throw or
crazy run so yeah he had some some
remember memorable moments
and and this year you know they've
beefed up just the right
just the right amount on the offensive
side he talked recently about how cole
beasley could potentially be a julian
edelman type of a safety valve for josh
allen and if you can give him a guy who
can get open underneath
when josh allen has that ever-present
threat to rocket the ball 80 yards down
the field right it becomes like the
chiefs with patrick mahomes where you
have to defend every blade of grass on
the defensive side of the ball because
josh allen has options at every level in
every spot and can get the football
there so i i'm excited by what what the
bills have done you know they didn't go
out and make huge splashes but they've
had stability you know they've got that
new england style offense which if if
you're right about tom brady there
should be a lot of open first reads for
josh allen as well brian dabal getting
things done for him i i i one of those
two teams is going to seriously contend
for a playoff berth and it may come down
to the quarterback play
and uh i think we both see yes those two
quarterbacks darnold allen making jumps
this season i would definitely do i mean
these were the the first two names i
wrote down were both of these guys and
yeah i went with darnold just because he
was new york as the jets and i thought
maybe you might forget about josh allen
to where i could steal him
but good job by you
okay i'm gonna go with rashad penny in
my second round pick from the seattle
seahawks rashad penny uh first round
pick out of san diego san diego state
two years ago right phenomenal football
player i loved them coming out in the
draft mike i really did and he showed
glimmers last year now he dealt with
injuries and training camp he got back
out showed us he's got something special
kind of got banged up again so he never
really got into the flow of the season
but he's a guy mike that averaged 4.9
yards per carry 419 yards and yeah it
was spotty to say the least but
regardless i look at that seattle
seahawks football team first of all they
drafted him in the first round so
they're going to want to prove that he
was worth the first round pick i think
he's going to get the
you know the lion's share of the carries
we know they want to be a run first
football team we've heard that you know
the last few weeks coming out of their
uh out of their organization and i think
he's super talented and they got a good
offensive line of course have russell
wilson to go along with it to keep some
pressure off them to where yeah i look
at rashad rashad penny to be one of
those guys this year that's in the top
five in the nfl and rushing statistics
when all said and done
yeah here's where i'll push back on a
little bit we know the seahawks embrace
competition in all forms except maybe
it's starting quarterback where they've
had opportunities in the past to upgrade
the backup but they don't want to
threaten russell wilson and then look he
gets it done so it's not like he needs
to have that artificial or actual
competition floating around him all
other positions it's compete compete
compete compete and chris carson right
there chris carson has been the guy and
they've been raving about what kind of
shape he's in i think pete carroll the
head coach of the team recently said
there's no one in better shape than
chris carson right now so rashad penny's
going to have to earn those reps he's
gonna have to take them away from carson
and i'm not sure he can do that to the
extent where he can end up having the
kind of major impact that would put him
on this list uh and and so it's it's a
little bit of a stretch a little bit of
a stretch but uh i i you know i i
thought he would do more last year and
again we're so we give him a lower base
going into 2019 maybe it does give him a
better opportunity to make a jump
because he didn't do all that much he
didn't do nearly as much as i thought he
would last year here's a guy that i have
a lot of faith in for the 2019 season
and it's keeping in line with part of
the theme of the day the the uh
quarterbacks the top 40. matt ryan came
in at number seven one of the guys he
throws to not named julio jones calvin
ridley and you know how much they like
calvin ridley and you know what we saw
out of calvin ridley last year and as
julio jones
continues to migrate on the wrong side
of 30 there could be more opportunities
for calvin ridley because look as long
as julio jones is around they're going
to double cover him and that's going to
open up opportunities and the question
is does he get on the field enough does
he get enough of the other opportunities
that don't go to julio jones and this is
that whole mohammed sunu calvin ridley
back and forth i think ridley could jump
sunu this year become the number two guy
and get a lot more opportunities than he
had in 2018 as a rookie and really make
a big jump especially if that falcons
offense takes off this year it's kind of
it's kind of a byproduct of our belief
that the falcons could be very very good
yes right if they are very very good
then calvin ridley is going to be one of
the reasons for it and he's going to
make that jump yep and mike and i think
you make the right points i mean yeah i
think he's going to surpass sunu as
being that true second guy i mean i
almost think he's going to go into the
stratosphere of like julio's 1a and
calvin ridley's 1b this year to where i
think he'll you know again you look at
calvin ridley's stats last year 64
receptions 8 21
10 touchdowns the 10 touchdowns that's
the aspect that like kind of you know is
eye-opening you go damn i forgot he
scored that many touchdowns but yeah i
mean i'm with you mike i think he is
gonna be you know part of the offense as
far as they're gonna build a package of
plays like they do with julio jones
every week and you're not gonna know
what to defend as far as a defense is
concerned and yeah i would expect julio
stats to come down a little bit
and some news to go up to where yeah
julio will lead the team in a lot of
categories but i don't think by much by
calvin
as far as calvin ridley so
good pick by you there not mad at you at
all and here's the thing he had he had
the 10 touchdowns in sneaky fashion last
year i think this year it's going to be
a and and he's it's i'm trying i'm
trying to defend my pick from the
standpoint of pointing out that yes he
has a higher platform because he already
said it was good just be quiet now
you're making the sound worse you're
actually making it worse the perception
is going to be the perception is going
to be who's this calvin ridley guy holy
crap look how good he is we already have
the evidence hiding in plain sight we
just didn't pay attention to it last
year that's my point
thank you counselor thank you for
hammering that home one more time thank
you very much you know what when i said
holy crap i came dangerously close to
saying something else yes uh so please
continue holy crap okay here we go um
i'm going with marcus davenport from the
new orleans saints ah you took my you
took the one i've been holding yeah
it's payback for taking josh allen there
you go yes marcus davenport davenport of
course hey last year was underwhelming
it wasn't good especially for a guy who
the saints traded up in the first round
with the green bay packers and traded
away assets to get a guy that they felt
was gonna be a huge difference maker on
their front four a guy that was a you
know gonna be on the other side of the
line from cam jordan you know a la von
miller and bradley chubb to where
they're gonna have this combination
where we're gonna go oh man watch out
davenport i believe has that potential
to be something big time special you
know
on the outside of the defense there he
really is big he's explosive he can
overpower you he's got pretty good bend
that way too i i expect this year with
him to be healthy you know some of the
things you've read down there i mean it
sounds like he's chomping at the bit uh
and he's going to want to prove his
worth to an organization that took a
risk on him and i i expect this year
davenport to be a guy that yeah i'm not
saying is you know more than
double-digit sacks but i think
you know like i always say uh he's gonna
mess a lot of plays up f a lot of plays
up and i think he's gonna have somewhere
between you know eight and a half and 12
sacks somewhere in that range
they gave up a lot to get him though
they gave up a first round pick this
year to move up in that trade with the
green bay packers in 2018 to get to
marcus davenport so far it has been a
disappointment so you know if you're
going to look at it from the standpoint
of he didn't do much last year here's
his opportunity cam jordan on the other
side of the line of scrimmage we'll see
what davenport can do but he was a guy
that i was eyeballing i had a couple i
was holding my back pocket now i
considered denzel ward but he had such a
great year last year you know i think he
is going to be better this year because
he's going to be dealing with a guy like
odell beckham jr in practice all the
time i'm going to stick with that
position though i'm going to jump
conferences i mentioned the packers
alexander is a guy they emerged from you
like that one from round one last year
with this guy can do it all he's a great
fit for the mike patton defense and he
he he's gotten electricity to him and
that is going to make him a a potential
star a guy that people are going to want
to interview we there was that moment
last year where he commandeered the desk
when football night in america was in
green bay and uh it's a funny guy he's
been on the show great personality and
and i think he's got the potential to
become a great great player and another
one of these guys where look he had a
strong rookie season but the packers
weren't very good right if the packers
are good we're going to notice him even
if they're not good we're going to
notice him and j alexander is going to
be a guy who gets a lot more attention
it's going to feel like he's making a
huge jump even though we saw plenty of
performance from him as a rookie yeah
right dealt with some injuries right
early on in his year so it took him some
some time to get on the field but he was
phenomenal when he got on i mean he's a
shutdown corner he's already you know in
the conversation from one of the best
man-to-man pure cover corners and all
the football that's how special he is
i'm with you mike that was a good pick
by you he was he was on my list if you
stole one of my other guys i would have
gone there
all right here's our recap chris sims
has sam darnov rashad penny marcus
davenport i've got josh allen calvin
ridley and jair alexander
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports